[Music]
i've worked 40 years in the council
secretariat and this will be the sixth
job that i have in the organization
and before that i was a swedish diplomat
for a few years and i studied law in
sweden
after my
studies
this job is about
the organization of all the official
meetings and events in the council
buildings so
the protocol and meetings directorate
coordinates these activities we're big
directors 200 people with a big budget
and we cooperate with all the services
in the gse on a daily basis so it's very
sociable and very dynamic
there isn't really a typical day in this
job
except that when in brussels i do have
many meetings
but it's with very different
interlocutors
it can be discovery day when welcoming
newcomers to the directorate but it can
also be with
belgian authorities to prepare big
events in brussels it can be on a
mission
abroad preparing
a visit of the president of the european
council
or being on the mission with him so
usually i know roughly what i'm going to
do when i arrive at work but sometimes
it doesn't turn out that way at all
and my previous posts have prepared me
for this job i think uh as a swedish
diplomat i participated in uh
sweden's first presidency of the council
so i have that perspective
i had several jobs as an aed in
different parts of the house
and my first management job was in the
swedish language unit
and there i learned really many things
but in particular the crucial importance
of the language issue in the council be
it in writing like for the translators
or orally as we need interpreters for
many of our meetings
and of course as head of the protocol
unit for the past three years i've also
learned a lot about the activities of
org ii and how we work with others so i
benefit from that now
and sometimes there are unexpected
things in the job
such as when
i accompanied the president tusk on a
visit to the border between tajikistan
and afghanistan he was going
the authorities were bringing him there
to
to look at the the work that they're
doing and he was also going to be
offered a lunch
fortunately i was not wearing heels flat
shoes but they were still just work in
ballerinas and you had to climb down in
uh like a gravel slope that was very
steep and it's also very high so it was
not so easy to breathe uh
but i managed that but the shoes were
completely ruined of course
so in org two
we coordinate the meetings that
should provide a good setting for
negotiations and also a good image of
the political stakeholders involved but
there's an enormous amount of
behind the scenes work involved so
the 200 staff in orbit are very busy
making sure that everything runs
smoothly
once the
the guests are here
but
i could talk a long time about all the
small steps that need to be taken by
many many people not just in org two but
also in other gse services
to make all this look perfect when it
takes place
this job is sometimes quite intense so i
do need to recharge at the end of the
day
and here i very often exercise and i
also enjoy cooking for my family this is
a kind of mental rest for me and
recently i went to a classical concert
again
for the first time in two years because
of kovid and this is something i need to
do more of too
[Music]
you